[Music]
on this Thursday night exclusive new
details on a Nova Scotia gunman's
cold-blooded rampage the crucial
information his girlfriend provided to
the police plus the people who just
missed running into the gunman I guess I
was really lucky Ontario's premier on
the out-of-control outbreaks in
long-term care homes any ways that the
system we didn't do better as Kovac 19
begins to spread inside Quebec hospitals
we're going through tough times
Plus planning for the new normal
Saskatchewan lays out a phased-in
strategy to start reopening the economy
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we have lots to get to tonight including
how outbreaks of kovat 19 in long-term
care homes are out of control in some
places especially Quebec and Ontario but
we begin with exclusive new information
about the mass murder in Nova Scotia 22
people were killed when a gunman went on
a rampage over the weekend the RCMP have
not released a timeline or much detail
about the chaotic 14 hours or so between
when the first call came in until the
gunman was shot and killed
but our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson is hearing some exclusive
details from her sources
Mercedes what can you tell us well Donna
were getting a little bit of a picture
of what happened that night before the
gunman's rampage he and his girlfriend
attended a party that was just down the
street from where his cottage was in
porta pick at that party I am told that
they got into an argument both left at
some point and went back to his cottage
at that point he escalated and became
violent with his girlfriend he assaulted
her and then he proceeded to tie her up
luckily Donna she managed to escape and
run into the woods after that at some
point the gunman goes out with a number
of firearms and he begins shooting
people including at the house where the
party was held then there's a bit of a
black hole we don't know what comes next
but the next thing that we learned that
is at 7:00 a.m. the next day
the RCMP find the gunman's girlfriend
she has been hiding and she is able to
give them critical information that
changes frankly the entire scope of the
investigation and how they're looking
for him she reveals to them that he is
likely dressed as a police officer and
driving an extremely realistic car that
looks just like an RCMP cruiser and she
in fact Donna is the person who provided
the picture to the RCMP that we all saw
on Twitter and how they got the news out
that he was impersonating a police
officer
so really critical information from
someone who had gone through so much
trauma but had managed to escape
Mercedes have you been able to discover
anything about the firearms used and
also how this all came to an end
so Donna we've learned that he had
access to a number of firearms and we
don't have an exact number but I can
tell you some of the types of firearms
that he had access to there was a
handgun including a handgun that he
stole from constable Heidi Stevenson
after he killed her he also had access
to a rifle and to a shotgun police are
still trying to figure out how he got
those guns and where they came from but
we do know those the types he had access
to I can tell you in terms of how this
all concluded on the second day on the
the Sunday he was out in the RCMP
cruiser at that point he ran into the
officer who was shot officer Morrison
and he shot him while he was driving by
that officers police cruiser
Heidi Stevenson the constable who died
in the line of duty then hears about the
fact that he's in a police car and spots
him my sources say she rammed him they
went off the road there was an exchange
of fire and he killed her he then takes
her sidearm he carjacked another car and
that is the silver car we heard about
ends up at a gas station where by chance
a member of the RCMP Emergency Response
Team and one of the k-9 officers pull in
they look across they see the car they
realize it is the gunman at that point
he reaches for his gun and the emergency
response team member opens fire and
kills him Mercedes that had to have been
an extremely chaotic and stressful
nearly 14 hours for the RCMP there are
lots of questions about why the public
was not alerted a gunman was on the
loose that night what does what you've
learned reveal about that did they think
they had him or at least had him
contained well they didn't realize he'd
slipped containment until the next day
and they've talked about that and I
think part of when they might have
realized that according to my sources is
that when he realized he might be in a
police uniform and I'm not clear on if
they knew exactly where he was before
that but there is certainly concern and
they are looking into whether that
police uniform on police car might have
helped him escape because if you're
looking for a gunman you're not looking
for a police officer so that's certainly
part of the investigation they're
looking into they're also looking into
the RCMP response there's questions
about training there's questions about
why as you say Donna an alert didn't go
out there was a tweet that went out
there
to a firearms complaint that didn't
quite describe what was happening which
was a mass shooting with fires
everywhere and that potentially could
have saved live so there's a lot of
questions about how all this was
communicated it's a very complex
investigation but on a bit of a more
human note Donna I can tell you for the
officers that were involved in this I've
been told it was extremely traumatic the
crime scenes that they were on were like
nothing they've experienced and there
will be a lot of healing to be done in
that community there sure will Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thanks the RCMP in
Nova Scotia did not hold a briefing
today the investigation as Mercedes says
is still in the early stages they are
mourning one of their own and there
remain many questions as Ross Lord
reports there are news stories emerging
of people grateful they didn't end up in
the gunman's path the more Nova Scotians
learned about the shooters movements the
more grateful some are that they left
the areas he visited just in time I was
really lucky because thinking about it
you know this would have been crime
scene number 17 almost an hour before he
was killed in a confrontation with our
CMP officers the suspect appeared to
stop his mock RCMP vehicle in a parking
lot he calmly got out to change his
clothes then continued driving up the
road
that's what appears to be shown in
surveillance video obtained by Global
News and originally posted to Facebook
on Wednesday only to be taken down
hours later minutes before that the
owners of a business at the same
location decided to close the shop
having just heard from friends on
Facebook about an active shooter in the
area and I'm grateful that he did
because if an RCMP officer pulled into
our parking lot my father wouldn't
hesitated to go outside to see if he
needed help or see if he needed anything
the gunman had a hit list according to a
man who says police told him he was on
it
nathan staples reportedly says
investigators told him the list was
found at a property of the shooter he
guesses the shooter listed him because
he refused to sell him a used police car
any Brunswick man who resells
decommissioned RCMP vehicles says the
gunman came to him almost two years ago
looking to make a purchase
describing himself as a retired Mountie
the reason that he wanted the card was
to put on his property to keep the
locals from steel and everything office
out of these cottages audio recordings
of first responders shed light on their
efforts at porta pick the first of 16
crime scenes one more coming
[Applause]
Nova Scotia RCMP had scheduled a news
conference for this evening but late
afternoon they called it off saying they
weren't ready
we're told a news conference is possible
tomorrow the same day as the virtual
vigil to remember those killed in this
tragedy Donna all right Ross Lord in
Halifax thanks we're learning more
tonight about some of the victims of
last weekend's murder rampage Global
News has now confirmed the identities of
20 of the 22 people killed in Nova
Scotia
among them were Ilana Jenkins and Sean
McLeod both were correctional officers
who had a passion for their careers each
other and their community if there was
to be balloons
ever any more love or any more
appreciated by a community I'll and it
was a real key to it all
she you know she got everybody together
the couple's home was burned down by the
killer on Sunday morning their neighbor
Tom Bagley was also killed while trying
to save MacLeod and Jenkins Oh their
neighbor was obviously daily walks on
fire of course Tom you talk why should
that be dried like and of course
unfortunately there was still back to
shooter buck was shot earlier
well Nova Scotians grieve they're also
dealing with the impact of Kovac 19
there were four more deaths in that
province today across Canada they are
now more than 42,000 confirmed cases
more than 2100 people are known to have
died Quebec has more than half the
cases in Canada nearly 22,000 people
there have tested positive for the virus
it also has the most deaths more than
1200 Quebecers have now died from Kovac
19 Ontario has more than 12,000
confirmed cases now and more than 700
people in that province have died from
the virus one of the positive cases in
Ontario is the mother-in-law of Ontario
Premier Doug Ford she's 95 she lives in
the West Park long-term care center in
Toronto 13 residents there have died of
kovat 19 there are hundreds of other
outbreaks in long-term care homes and
today who is obvious the premier and the
Prime Minister know the anguish that's
causing and you see a loved one with her
elderly parent and they put their hand
up against the window that's
heartbreaking anyways the system we
didn't do better we are failing our
parents our grandparents our elders the
greatest generation who built this
country we need to care for them
properly there have been requests for
military assistance by both Ontario and
Quebec which of course we will be
answering but this is not a long-term
solution in Canada we shouldn't have
soldiers taking care of seniors soldiers
taking care of seniors it's happening
all over Quebec now and parts of Ontario
they're filling the gaps left by
hundreds of staff who aren't working
anymore because they've tested positive
or are too afraid of the risk and now
hospitals in Quebec are starting to seek
ovid 19 spread within their wards as
Mike Armstrong reports some say it's a
time bomb waiting to go off with just
about every day that passes this
Montreal Cancer Center changes its
practices reacting to the threat of
kovat 19 cancer patients showing up for
treatment have their own door they're
also called the day before and
pre-screened they're asked if they have
symptoms of kovat 19 that said some
nervous their treatment could be put off
don't tell the truth
in one case someone was coping positive
and came in there and so the nurses had
to leave and be quarantined and being
tested more and more hospitals are
dealing with outbreaks and they seem to
be hitting the most vulnerable at this
hospital there were outbreaks in both
the oncology and dialysis wards 34
outpatients only showing up for
treatments instead caught kovat 19 from
patients in the institution never tried
to keep that isolated but it's almost
impossible there is a case in Montreal
of a man who was staying at this
hospital to have his medication changed
his daughter says he instead contracted
and died from kovat 19 he says she was
reassured there was no danger the
coronavirus cases were on a different
floor no the other impact of the virus
is on healthcare workers themselves more
and more are off the job in Quebec the
premier says about 4,000 have tested
positive but another 5,500 are off as a
precaution or even over anxiety or
burnout unfortunately the situation is
getting worse than worse because today
we have 800 people more missing some
long-term care facilities are without 50
to 70% of their staff in some cases it's
not kovat 19 sending seniors to
emergency rooms it's that staff can't
keep up with basic needs like food and
water they didn't have ever they weren't
having really difficulties but they were
sick because they were dehydrated now
five military medical teams hit the
ground earlier this week but that was a
drop in the bucket
while Ottawa agreed Thursday to send
1000 soldiers and Quebec long-term care
facilities they won't be trained going
in but the extra hands are desperately
needed Mike Armstrong global news want
Rio
lots of people across the country we're
watching the premier of Saskatchewan
closely today Scott Moe laid out the
most comprehensive plan yet for
gradually lifting some restrictions on
our lives it applies only to
Saskatchewan and it won't get life back
to normal but instead to a new normal as
Eric Sorenson explains it paints a
picture of what life for all of us could
look like one day Saskatchewan is ready
to blaze a trail slowly to get its
economy and life moving again starting
in early May all medical services will
be available including dentistry fishing
can start and boat launch is used in
mid-may golf but with restrictions for
example new precautions such as an
elevated cup the ball just hits the hole
no hands going down into the cup
starting May 19th some retailers can
open they include clothing shoes flowers
sporting goods and some personal
services can open like hairdressers
barbers registered massage therapists so
no date yet for restaurants bars fitness
facilities and childcare much later
still indoor and outdoor recreation and
entertainment facilities in all cases
gatherings of no more than ten people
all the while trying to limit the spread
of kovat 19 we have to find the middle
ground that continues to keep our case
numbers low and keep Saskatchewan people
safe while at the same time allowing for
businesses to reopen and Saskatchewan
people to get back to work how can
Saskatchewan do it
it's outbreak is relatively under
control Saskatchewan saw its first case
in early March but there was never a big
surge there were 30 cases on March 28th
but then down from there in fact just
single digits over the last two weeks
when we'll other provinces reopened
Saskatchewan plan now out Quebec
Manitoba and Alberta say they'll have an
update on their plans by next week New
Brunswick and Pei have plans in the
works they say and for Ontario and BC so
far they say no changes before sometime
in May a time frame that likely applies
to all provinces the plan recognizes the
economy can't stand still forever
health experts see the need for balance
there needs to be a real tug-of-war but
you know slowing the spread of the virus
down but obviously not being able to
eliminate the spread but at the same
time being able to open up some of our
industries so that we can start to
function again saskatchewan x' is the
first detailed plan others are watching
Eric Sorensen Global News the virus has
left all of us cooped up inside for
weeks now lots of people getting itchy
to get outside especially as the weather
warms up coming up the balance between
keeping people safe and sane
for the first time in almost a century
the Calgary Stampede has been canceled
event organizers say it was a difficult
decision but the right thing to do the
world-famous rodeo drew more than 1.2
million visitors last year it was set to
begin in Calgary on July 3rd there's no
way to keep physically distant at the
Stampede there are key things that have
to happen before it can go ahead again
and the economy can reopen a vaccine
that works and aggressive testing today
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau announced
1.1 billion dollars will be devoted to
that the plan has three components one
hundred and fifteen million dollars for
research into vaccines and treatments
being developed in Canadian hospitals
and universities 662 million for
clinical trials and 350 million to
expand national testing and modeling for
kovat 19 the prime minister also
announced the creation of a new co vyd
19 immunity task force it will focus on
serology testing that's blood based
tests to determine if someone has been
exposed to the virus and may be immune
they'll be looking at key questions like
how many people beyond those we've
already tested have had covent 19th
whether you're immune once you've had it
and if so how long that lasts over the
next two years the plan is to test 1
million Canadians next a look at the
latest economic impact in the u.s.
because of Kovach 19
millions more people have lost their
jobs in the United States more than 4
million laid off workers filed for
unemployment benefits last week that
means roughly 26 million Americans have
now lost their jobs just in the past
five weeks the latest Department of
Labor figures show the pace of layoffs
in the US has slowed slightly but
there's a backlog of claims so millions
more are likely to file in the coming
weeks the number of confirmed cases
continues to soar in the u.s. more than
850,000 people have tested positive for
covin 19 and that only reflects those
who have been tested deaths are also
climbing the official number surpassed
48 thousand today in New York alone more
than 15,000 people are now known to have
died from kovat 19 next experts reality
check how your summer dreams will be
affected by Kovach 19
we've been taking your questions about
Kovac 19 to the experts and right now
people are looking ahead to the summer
wanting to know if they'll need to alter
their plans
Jeff simple is here with some of the
answers Jeff well Donna Canadians have
been stuck indoors for weeks now and
with the arrival of warmer weather many
are now wondering when they'll be able
to step outside and play I'm a golfer
and very keen to get back on the course
and but want to do so safely when it
comes to outdoor activities provinces
are taking different approaches several
like Ontario have locked down the links
but many of BC's golf courses are in
full swing
similarly federal and provincial parks
are closed until at least the end of May
but many municipal parks and private
campsites remain open if you are outside
and you are more than 2 metres away from
other people then you should get outside
I think where public health starts to
worry is do people actually comply with
that what a walk in the park is one
thing what about walking down the aisle
my question is in regards to my wedding
that is upcoming in May and the groups
of people that are allowed to congregate
Alberta has band gatherings of more than
15 people in Ontario no more than five
are allowed this BC couple was planning
to invite 135 wedding guests but settled
for a few family members in their living
room and their first dance in the street
if weddings are able to go on they're
probably going to be smaller groups and
recommendations about spacing out the
people hi my name is Karen Fleming is
there any work being done or looking at
the cost of how to prevent a future
scenario China recently announced a ban
on wildlife markets like the one in
Wuhan where the outbreak started but
some of those have already reopened this
needs a long-term solution for both
China and every other country in the
world that is selling wildlife but it's
worth remembering that the SARS outbreak
is also believed to have started at a
live animal market in China and at the
time fourteen years ago there were
plenty of promises made for changes to
ensure that nothing like that ever
happened again Donna if simple in
Toronto Thanks well in the midst of all
those birthdays are still being
celebrated without big parties of course
we thought we'd leave you with this cute
two-year-old Prince Louie is the
youngest child of the Duke and Duchess
of Cambridge and she took these pictures
he's making a rainbow hand print picture
a tribute to health care workers
he looked perfect at first and then just
like any other kid the palace captioned
this Instagram versus reality
Prince Charles marked his birthday with
this sweet photo taken before the
pandemic he's doing what every
grandparent longs to do again give their
grandkids a hug thanks for watching and
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you